The Yale veteran
community is truly amazing.
And I think that's because
the administration here makes it
feel like veterans
really belong at Yale.
Hi, my name is Mikaela Cardillo.
I'm a third year student at
Yale Law School.
I served five years in the Navy
as a surface warfare officer.
I went to the Naval Academy
right out of high school.
I wanted to do something
that was greater than myself
but then also sort of
see the world
outside of my hometown
in Indiana.
Veterans Day is
a time to reflect
on the sacrifice that veterans
have made for this country.
We all took an oath to defend
American ideals,
and we all took that
with an understanding
that we could possibly
give our lives for those ideals.
People are grateful.
Your country is grateful
for your service
and the sacrifices that you made